what do I keep with me every night in
bed a your husband
a packet of biscuits in case I get
hungry
B air pods because my own snoring wakes
me up okay we'll see a stuffed toy
animal called bunny bunny yeah yes
what yeah
when did you get bunny the day I was
born
very old it doesn't look anything like
it doesn't doesn't remotely resemble a
bunny rabbit anymore she's so old but
my koala as well oh you do oh good do
you sleep with it every night though
every night so okay
and my husband this because he's like
this is so weird that we have to be in
bed number he waits until he thinks I'm
asleep and then he throws bunny out of
bed no yeah and I get so mad I'm like
everybody out of bed ah the things bunny
has seen yeah well no I shouldn't see
that